nous avons un vrai bordel, c'est un [ __ ] d'ours,
c'est un ours,
nous attendons cet ours toute ma vie
non, j'ai pitié, c'est le meilleur traqueur, je
sais que c'est un boucher,
quelqu'un va s'en prendre à ce truc avec lequel tu
t'occupes de ton frère,
viens avec  tu étais prêt à aller voir
le grizzly, mae n'a pas rendu hommage au
chien, je ne peux pas faire celui-ci seul, il y a un
ours tueur ici, trois personnes sont
déjà mortes cette fois,
nous restons ensemble dans le labyrinthe des grizzlis,
même les grizzlis peuvent se perdre  là,
les ours ont peur on dirait qu'ils
quittent tous le labyrinthe comme s'ils fuyaient
quelque chose je pense que nous avons un
problème nous sommes dans la zone de mise à mort tu vois
cette bière tu la tues c'est comme si ton
ours nous traquait
ça  Ce n'est pas un ours moyen, c'est un
ours intelligent, tu vas saigner, tague-
le avec notre meilleur coup, mec, le
labyrinthe d'Eden,
il est de retour,
cet ours, il n'a pas faim de territoire, il est énervé quand
un grizzly se met en colère, vous avez tous
le même goût.